[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
en Méditerranée la France face aux jeux
des puissances
un quart des flux du commerce mondial
transit par la Méditerranée la stabilité
de cet espace situé à l'interface entre
trois continents est indispensable que
peut la France face aux jeux des
puissances dans cet espace situé dans
son voisinage immédiat dans leur rapport
fait au nom de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées les sénatrices Catherine
Dumas et Isabelle Raymond pavot formule
cette recommandation la Méditerranée ou
circule des flux de marchandises et
d’énergie des flux d'information et des
flux humains est un espace de plus en
plus vulnérable fragilisée par des
risques sécuritaires socio-économiques
et environnementaux
en matière de sécurité le bassin
méditerranéen reste par exemple soumis à
la persistance d'un risque djihadiste
sur le plan économique et social la
guerre en Ukraine se grenier à blé des
pays méditerranéens apparaît comme un
nouveau facteur de déstabilisation alors
que la pandémie de covid 19 avait déjà
eu des conséquences lourdes la pêche et
l'intensification du trafic maritime et
du tourisme provoque une dégradation
préoccupante du milieu marin
cet espace stratégique est de plus en
plus disputé il comprend des zones
grises revendiquer simultanément par
plusieurs états pouvant faire craindre
des risques d'affrontement direct comme
plusieurs incidents maritimes en
Méditerranée orientale l'ont déjà
illustré alors que le risque d'une
militarisation des relations
internationales s'intensifient les
États-Unis et dans une moindre mesure
l'Union européenne voit leur influence
décroître
à l'inverse Chine et Russie
réinvestissent la zone sur le plan
économique diplomatique et militaire des
acteurs régionaux comme la Turquie
l'Egypte et l'Algérie cherche aussi à
s'imposer dans ce contexte si la France
veut contribuer à assurer la stabilité
dans l'espace méditerranéen elle a un
rôle à jouer aux côtés de l'Union
européenne et de l'Alliance atlantique
pour décourager les remises en cause du
droit international fait valoir le
rapport sénatorial la commission appelle
donc à renforcer la résilience de la
France en cas de conflit en Méditerranée
et recommande de moderniser la stratégie
de l'UE dans le bassin méditerranéen
enfin le rapport plaide pour une
rationalisation de la coopération entre
l'Union européenne et l'OTAN dans cette
région méditerranéenne au combien
stratégique
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]